bonjour nous sommes très heureux de vous avoir tous les deux
ici ce soir
boris blanc et dieter miller alors
quand vous étiez avant vous étiez membre de
yellow ewell un chauffeur de camion est-il vrai
c'est vrai oui et vous écriviez de la
musique pendant la nuit et le jour
vous  écoutais ta musique
dans ton camion et tu as eu beaucoup d'accidents
non n'est-ce pas
le dernier des derniers mois j'ai fait trois
accidents complets toute la
voiture a été brisée alors
la société pour qui je travaille euh dis-moi
maintenant
la situation une surancy ou  comment s'appelle
ouais l'assurance l'assurance ne paierait
plus
pour ces accidents je savais que ton père
était un homme très riche c'est un c'est un
homme très riche c'est un banquier je connais un banquier très
célèbre et
riche je ne sais pas s'il est riche  ou pas
il va bien souvent c'est un banquier ouais mais je
sais pas du tout t'es pas
impliqué dans le rock and roll tu
dis qu'un
français qui joue du rock and roll c'est comme
un japonais
euh qui joue à la jonglerie c'est pour dire toi toi
toi  pense que ce n'est pas notre
culture et yo  tu n'es pas du tout dedans
oui je pense que
tu sais qu'on nous demande en amérique ou en
angleterre où nous
avons du succès euh on nous demande toujours
comment se fait-il qu'en dehors de la suisse
quelque chose comme ça puisse arriver
et je dis toujours que nous sommes  très
provincial
dans la mesure où nous n'essayons pas de copier le
rock and roll parce que ce ne sont pas nos
racines musicales ouais
et c'est pourquoi je pense par exemple
en france si je puis dire que beaucoup de
musique
ne revient tout simplement pas aux racines
france  a musicalement mais c'est comme une culture
importée et juste reprise
comme euh quand je mets un nouveau contrôleur tu
sais et c'est quelque chose
qui n'est pas vraiment profond parce que ça
ne vient pas de tes racines
c'est quelque chose qui vient de te mettre
comme un autocollant  et puis
vous jouez du rock and roll vous pouvez être très
parfait en le faisant mais il n'a pas d'âme
qu'en est-il de votre nouveau votre nouvel album
appelé drapeau
vous dites que c'est le plus jaune de notre
album qu'est-ce que cela signifie drapeau est comme une
devise pour vous maintenant  je pense que c'est
très difficile  C'est la situation pour un musicien
ou pour tous ceux qui créent
quelque chose
si euh soudainement je veux dire soudainement au
cours des trois quatre dernières années nous avons eu plus de succès public
tu as ce succès c'est comme si les
gens te
lançaient de l'or ouais et cet objectif peut bien euh te tuer
vous savez à la manière de James Bond, si vous êtes
couvert d'or, vous ne respirez
plus, vous êtes un doigt légal
et cet album drapeau et le titre
signifient
que nous essayons de maintenir l'
identité
du petit drapeau de notre  des petites idées en
face de la situation où du coup
on doit se sentir responsable de tout l'
argent
qu'on gagne parce qu'on a réussi
alors maintenant on va jouer à un petit jeu
c'est une sorte d'interview qu'on fait assez
souvent dans cette émission
ça s'appelle l'interview wuzu
si  je vais vous dire brian ferry que
pensez-vous de brian ferry brian ferry est un
artiste très classique un vrai crooner un
entrepreneur classique qui quand la
musique roxy a commencé avait inventé un tout
nouveau style de musique nous devrions n  jamais
oublier que
nous étions entourés de rock and roll ouais
quand il a eu euh commencé avec la musique roxy
et il est toujours en quelque sorte le père de
tout un euh nouveau mouvement d'
accord double de très bons amis à moi ont
eu hier un appel téléphonique
ouais avec euh un membre de
oui  ce sont des amis à nous ouais vous
appréciez ce qu'ils font
oui oui je pense qu'ils sont de très bons euh
auteurs-compositeurs pour être un peu critiques ouais je
me sens
critique soyons critiques euh je
souhaiterais qu'ils
soient un peu plus
aventureux dans leur euh production  vous savez, je pense qu'ils sont
très doués, donc classiques, vous voulez dire
qu'ils sont un peu trop lisses à mon goût d'
accord la
prochaine tasse je pense que c'est le contraire du
travail d'artisanat jaune qu'ils veulent devenir comme des
machines comme des robots
qu'ils aiment être des robots et que le jaune
utilise  high-tech ouais la nouvelle technologie
comme les bongos du 20ème siècle on
ne
euh on est pas impressionné par la technologie on l'
utilise
ouais et ils aimeraient être technique
ils aimeraient être robo ok donc c'est
l'inverse
ok en parler parce que tu es assez je
déteste les
sports ah tu les détestes ouais non je déteste
la
voix de david burns ouais c'est vraiment ça
colle exactement ici la musique que j'aime
j'aime beaucoup très radical
je pense
bien c'est quelque chose dont les gens
disent aussi  nous je pense qu'ils sont parfois
un peu trop
euh arty un peu trop étudiants en art tu sais
et euh récemment je veux dire depuis
quelques années ils essaient de s'éloigner
de ça en utilisant
euh des rythmes très noirs en
quelque sorte très roulants
lectures et je pense que c'est un très très
bon
développement pour eux, mais fondamentalement,
je les aime surtout en sachant à
quel point il est difficile de créer
quelque chose d'individuel
en Amérique dans ce secteur, vous savez que
c'est la chose la plus difficile au monde
à traverser les murs  de l'ignorance en
Amérique
qu'en est-il du prince
so-so et toi le prince pour moi
est virtuose il est un conglomérat
de génie de toutes sortes d'idées différentes il est
un brillant
arrangeur et je pense que
tous ensemble
euh  un peu trop souvent un peu trop souvent
l'image qu'il est pour moi comme un magicien
qui avait une boîte devant lui et
il sort
ce prince ce prince ou voulez-vous
ce prince ou ce prince
j'étais un grand fan de de de  zappa je pense
qu'il était
très humoristique et il avait beaucoup d'
auto-ironie
dans tout son truc le genre d'
approche funky jazzy rocky qu'il avait musicalement au
bout d'un moment est devenu un peu ennuyeux pour moi
tant d'albums et le dernier mais non le moindre
jimi hendrix
sympa  bon guitariste
était probablement qu'il était
trop petit sur cette planète super personnage
est-il vrai que tu vendras à paris
euh ouais ouais j'essaie de trouver
un appartement ici ouais parce que j'aime paris
et j'aime jimi hendrix
méthamphétamine